[Music]
all right guys here we are we are in the
jungle we are deep in the jungle I
believe I am discovering new land New
Territories you can see this as real as
it gets I have had no water no food I
have been catching fish with my bare
hands that I do not even recognize they
have three heads I am hallucinating out
here I have had zero contact with the
outside world and that's a yes we just
keep the head on me and see that like I
was saying I'm discovering new land
welcome to Jumanji you ruined a shot son
of a [ __ ] you're ruining shot Oh
Productions just got shut down here on a
set of Jemima not because of weather not
because of the crazy environment that
was shooting in because Jack Black
needed to finish his Russian Jack you
good I'm good
yeah we're Jack's and I'm not shooting
[ __ ] so I finished my damn right ain't
that right jack there's some good stuff
yes right
Jack said you can kiss my ass production
can wait you okay jack go away big guy
what is she coming out the jungles of
Jumanji are amazing but you got to be
careful cuz a lot of mosquitoes and the
Skeets come out at night
he's come at night the skis go at night
kids come out at night well v come out
all right it's 3:00 a.m. on set we just
wrapped here on Jumanji these fans right
here I got the greatest fans in the
world they have literally been waiting
out here somewhere I don't know 9 12
hours or something like that here the
hell right here okay all right all right
good to meet you good night
you